N-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-nice!
Nice!
Ehehe!
WIR BELTooooooooooooooooooooo!
die
L
Das Sine and Pain ist am Start. Elf Monate in Folge.
Poggers.
Was soll der Titel, der bald stimmt?
Ich muss gerade mal kurz die Fragen vom letzten Mal noch aufräumen.
Dann blick ich da aber an, damit wir durch was schon beantwortet haben, was nicht.
Was soll der Titel, der bald stimmt?
Das haben wir eh vor.
Die Frage kommt immer wieder, das muss man eigentlich mal als Kommando beantworten.
B, S, P, W, M testen.
Ich hab gehört, das ist alles bloated.
Alles, alles bloated.
Laut Twitch existierte übrigens gar nicht.
Laut Twitch hab ich null Zuschauer.
Alles, alles bloated.
Ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt, der gesagt hat, alles bloated außer DWM.
Allerdings seh ich den Grund überhaupt nicht zu wechseln.
Ich finde E3 eigentlich super.
E3 hat alles vollmäßig so, oder fast alles, wie ich's haben will.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund.
Alles bloated.
Oh Gott, ich hab gestern Abend, wo ich das hier gerade sehen wollte,
ich hab gestern Abend, das hätt ich nicht machen sollen.
Das war nicht gut für meine Gehirnzellen.
Ich hab das, ich hab ne halbe Stunde dazugehört.
Ich hab das, ich hab ne halbe Stunde das Video geguckt von,
vom Inscope21Niko und wie heißt der andere, der dabei ist?
Gabel oder so, kann das sein?
Schon wieder, nee, nee, heute zum Glück kein C++.
Das ist noch auf vom letzten Mal.
Das war gleich mal wieder zu C++.
Ich hätt's nicht machen sollen.
Ich hätte mir das nicht angucken sollen, Alter.
Das hat mir mal wieder die Abgründe von YouTube Deutschland gezeigt, Alter.
Und nicht nur von YouTube Deutschland, ja, aber überhaupt.
Was ist das denn?
Kennst du dich ein bisschen mit Dark Souls aus?
Nee, hab ich keine Ahnung von.
Die Basics von Awakensk
Die Basics, ja.
Oh man, das hat echt wehgetan, das Video.
Ich hab's auch nicht ganz angeguckt,
Ich habe ein bisschen drüber geskippt und ich habe dann ich konnte mir den scheiß nicht mehr geben
Das ist das ist so leute
Den kls song nein nein den kenne ich nicht und ich will den auch nicht hören
Hör auf aber du hast mitbekommen dass die beiden verarscht wurden ja ja
Wie gesagt das video meine ich ja das habe ich mir gestern abend angeguckt das hat mir mit den kompletten abgründe von von youtube und
diesen ganzen
Da ist er da
Das ist ja da nicht der einzige es gibt so viel guck mal ich habe ich habe letztes ich habe video gesehen
Dings hier Simon des
Der nicht desmond wie heißt das Simon des jude hat jetzt auch in so eine komische
Instagram academy wo du die krassen influencer tricks lernst und sowas
Was ich habe piss dich alde
ist das denn
Das ist ein fehler von
mit fremdorf heißt das piss dich alde copypunkt bng und hier ist das original piss dich alde
Ok was ist das
Das kann ich vielleicht kann ich
Vor allem wie sich die leute dann teilweise immer verarschen lassen so geil
Also ich meine jetzt nicht das bezogen auf die geschichte mit das video was vom liko geguckt habe sondern
Allgemein dass da so viele drauf reinfallen immer noch
Kommen die instagram gruppe nämlich instagram gruppe was ist es whatsapp gruppe
und du machst
35.000 euro am tag bänbänbän cash leute cash das krasse business wird gestartet
Kommt mal klar auf euer leben der krasse bus ist komm in die gruppe das ist so ein schwachsinn
Das da die masche ist ja auch nicht neu ich meine dass
Das ist eine whatsapp gruppe ist es neu aber unter dem strich
Und sind das meistens in irgendeine art und weise
irgendwelche schneeballsysteme die man ja offiziell wie nennt man das
Struktur marketing ne ach keine ah
Aber im prinzip sind sie ja fast alles so was wie schneeballsysteme
Und dass da die leute heute noch drauf reinfallen
Halm die holländer haben es erfunden
Das stimmt
Warum ist jetzt auf einmal überall ein keck keck w hintendran
Jetzt ist es weg
Also immer gibt es hier eine wette dass die bandbreite wieder ein bricht das können wir tatsächlich mal machen
Wir können jetzt wir können wann kackt oder faun wieder ab
Wir können jetzt wieder ab
Jetzt bis 30 minuten wir sind ja wieder 22
Also so in 30 minuten in 60 minuten oder in 90 minuten Also wer am nächsten also dass es zählt das was am nächsten dran ist
Es zählt das was am nächsten dran ist